depuis des semaines tout le monde ne
parle que de ça le coronavirus
représente une urgence de santé publique
mais aussi une menace pour la croissance
puisque la crise provoquée par
l'épidémie frappe de plein fouet
l'économie mondiale qui se dirige tout
droit vers une récession
les principales bourses d'asie essuient
une lourde perte
victime de la propagation du virus mais
aussi de l'effondrement du marché du
pétrole les cours de l'or noir qui ont
connu ce lundi leur pire chute depuis la
première guerre du golfe en 91 se sont
effondrées de plus de 30 % en asie une
crise due en partie au conflit entre la
russie et l'arabie saoudite deux des
trois plus gros producteurs mondiaux et
face à la chute de la consommation ces
derniers n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre
pour réduire leur production
une réunion de crise a eu lieu avec les
13 pays de l'organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole et moscou s'est
opposé à une nouvelle réduction d 1,5
million de barils par jour et a donc
décidé de faire cavalier seul et en
réponse à cela et bien ryad a déclenché
une véritable guerre des prix entraînant
la chute des cours du brut
alors pour vous donner une idée des
conséquences sur les coûts en est
actuellement à 35 dollars le baril de
pétrole contre 70 dollars juste avant
l'épidémie prenait la chine par exemple
qui est le premier consommateur de brut
mondial 14 % de la demande soit 14
millions de barils par jour l'europe
n'est pas épargnée et les bourses du
continent sont également en chute libre
et tout le monde ya droit lé pays avec
une économie fragile vont en pâtir les
premiers le venezuela l'algérie l'iran
ou encore le nigeria et qui risque de
basculer dans des crises économiques et
sociales à cause d'un prix du brut et
qui s'effondrent les mesures saoudienne
sur le prix du pétrole pourrait donc
avoir un rôle crucial dans la crise
économique mondiale vers laquelle nous
nous dirigeons peut-être